you're watching film courage yeah
hello everyone Karen born with film
courage live radio show i'm here with
half of the vacation ears Jeff grace
Louise Miller and Jeff wants me to use
my super duper radio voice so i am going
to do that for you right now we had some
questions come in from our lovely
friends King as a Fink Julie kak and
Jessica King and they want to know for
you gentlemen how did you assemble your
team of people i mean how did you know
that they were the right team to work
with a lot of people in LA I think
really just trial and error Jeff and I
moved out to Los Angeles around the same
time and started working with a bunch of
different groups and some of them worked
and someone didn't and we found a good
core group of guys to work with and
everyone kind of feels their own role
and then once you find that group other
people start coming into the group
because they see your good doing good
stuff yeah I hear that yeah i think you
mean it's also so you got to put work in
that like isn't fun like you have to
work on other people's projects and be a
extra in there are short film and hold
the boom mic for a day where you're not
in it you know you can't always just be
like well i'll do it if i have a really
great part you have those like I mean I
find this process fun i hope most people
do but now you got to be willing to do a
lot of that grunt work because they also
can do a favor almost would you want to
do it you know yeah like we're working
with these guys for film called
superzeros and like blaze help them out
with their casting you know I you know
we just like help help them their script
and stuff like that and you know
basically by collaborating you know you
know hopefully work on their film a
little bit yeah when we have the next
film you'll be helping us out with that
they're they're shooting at a Nashville
end of August beginning in September
cool cool group of guys music video
directors down there Jason Fonzarelli
Travis Nicholson and they're you know
they're doing the same thing that we're
doing so the more we all work together
the more we're going to be doing stuff
together in the future so you're doing
film festivals and you're funny guys you
have to be on all the time do you ever
get burned out other days that you just
don't
wanna be Karen I'm so lucky so bad wait
uh we I don't I think actually as
comedians go I think we're pretty easy
to hang out with cuz we're not those
guys were always like you know the Robin
Williams effect you're like oh yeah well
let me tell you Karen that's a great
question you know I've been specialized
in sort of in dark comedy a little bit
too it's it's it hasn't been like big
sticky sticky steines stuff so we are
made the comedian's a claim that we're
not always on but that probably when
people hang out with us they'd be like
what those guys are always on there so
annoying oh I hate him yeah just be
yourself try or try or create a persona
that looks like you're trying to be
yourself like I'm doing right now
absolutely I working I like you McCarron
you have a radio voice and you have a
real life voice you know it's kids okay
hey this is Karen warden with Phil
courage signing out we hear your real
voice now I think you should sign up
with your real voice
you